- [Narrator] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
non-commercial use only.
(upbeat music)
- We're very pleased to have
as our Jefferson lecture,
a person, a scholar who,
lives up to really remarkable history
of this lecture series which
as you see from your program
goes back to 1958, and has included
some of the leading figures
in public intellectual life
and political life and journalism
and above all in scholarship.
These lectures were established in 1944
through a bequest from Elizabeth Bonestell
and her husband Cutler Bonestell,
San Francisco couple that
cared a lot about history
and hope that lectures on
the democratic tradition
Thomas Jefferson and the
values of American democracy
would be of interest to this community.
Today's lecturer is John Witte.
Who is a professor at Emory University,
where he holds a distinguished chair
and where is headed a
center, a remarkable center
which is engaged in studies
of religion and law for many years.
It's always been a matter
of astonishment to me
how, first of all his own career,
he's been ahead of the
curve by about 15 years.
And just thinking about
such questions as religion
and the post-soviet Russia,
are thinking about
Islam and the challenges
that are migration such as
we experience would generate.
And and he very kindly met
with a group of students
and faculty at lunch today,
and lo and behold he
said that their objective
was to get 15 years ahead of the curve
so it was on purpose.
But with immense success,
that he's done this.
His detailed biography is in your program,
and I encourage your
reading all those details
of a distinguished career
in which he's made mark,
as a leading scholar and thinker
in my own field of history.
He's a great authority
on questions of law and religion
in Protestant Europe from
the early modern period
down to the present, he's
written on the First Amendment
as a constitutional scholar.
He teaches in these fields
and has also taught in
criminal law other fields
and has given lectures of this sort
and Dowd lectures, in which
an institution seeks to bring
the very top tier person in a given field
that many other just fine
institutions in this country.
And there's almost
latest book and 2009 book
on some themes that may
be touched on today,
called the Sins of the Gathers
on legitimacy, Issue of Illegitimacy.
There are two reviews that
I just like to quote briefly
because I couldn't say them better myself
and I couldn't say with
half the tenth the authority
that these people have said it.
David Ford, the Regis
professor of Divinity
Cambridge University refers to John Witte
as one of the world's foremost
thinkers on law and religion.
a man whose work is noted
for rigorous scholarship,
perceptive theology in wise reflections
on civic responsibility and
other aspects of the subject.
And David Novak, the Shiff
professor of Jewish Studies
at Toronto, says that
this book demonstrates
what we always expect from John Witte.
Painstaking historical
research, lucid presentation
plus jurisprudential and
theological gravitas.
And also the profound
humanity of this man.
Those of us, there are
many in law and history
and religious studies who are his friend,
would also say it's an
incomplete introduction
without referring to his
brilliance as a teacher
and his profound humanity.
So it with very great
pleasure that I present
Professor John Witte as this
semester's Jefferson Lecture
and he's gonna speak
on Sharia in the West.
What place for religious legal systems
in America and other
democracies, thank you.
(audience clapping)
- Well thank you very
much Professor Scheiber
for your warm and very
generous introduction.
Good afternoon to each of you,
it's a great pleasure to be
back on this beautiful campus
and this lovely time of the year.
To have the chance to partake
of the intellectual Sparkle of this place,
and to enjoy the faculty and the students
whom I've had the privilege
to meet again here.
I wanna thank all of you for
taking the time to be with us
in the late afternoon when
beautiful skies beckon,
and the beach is closed
and margaritas are flowing
in some venue of the city.
I wanna thank Ellen
Gobler and her colleagues
for their special
choreography of this event
and the wonderful
hospitality they've accorded.
I wanna thank my dear
friend Harry Scheiber,
for the great hospitality
that he has accorded me
together with his wonderful bride Jane
for his brilliant
scholarship in legal history
and economic history, of which I
and many thousands of others
have been the happy beneficiaries,
and for his uncommon kindness to me
in the last decade and more.
And opening doors and opportunities
and inviting me to
participate in various things
not least this distinguished lectureship.
I wanna thank the members
of the Jefferson Lecture
Committee for their kindness
and lowering their
standards to allow an unripe
and unworthy youngster to stand before you
to deliver this lecture this afternoon.
As I was looking over the long roll
of distinguished speakers who
have stood here before me,
I could not help but feel a
sharp pang or two of inadequacy,
and I could not help but remember
the rather embarrassing
experience of my good friend Bryan
in our first year class
and contracts together
some 25 years ago at
the Harvard Law School.
The class was taught by
the Venerable Archibald
Cox of Watergate Fame,
master of Socratic dialogue and repartee
and I note a prior Jefferson lecturer.
Bryan was a particularly gifted student,
he had been trained in rhetoric
and in drama at Radcliffe College,
he had been a national debating champion,
he had been a professional actor
even appearing in a part
and a play on Broadway
before Law School.
And so when Professor Cox called on Bryan
to recite the first case of the day,
Bryan initially held forth
with considerable aplomb.
Professor Cox of course had
only begun his interrogation.
And he began to press
his line of questions
a bit more closely, and
Bryan found that the answers
did not fall nearly so
easily off his tongue.
Cox became more insistent now
lashing out his Socratic whip
with increasing alacrity
and increasing accuracy.
Bryan became more and more confused,
Cox became even more insistent
and when the questions
threatened to overwhelm him,
Bryan summoned up the
little courage he had left
looked professor Cox on the eye
and repeated a line from his drama days,
"Sir, I am afraid I am teetering
"on the edge of the
abyss of my ignorance."
Cox's reply was instantaneous.
"Young man you fell into
that abyss some time ago."
(audience laughing)
While standing up here
experimenting with questions
at the edge of family
law and Islamic identity
and religious freedom and women's rights,
and other fundamental rights,
I too feel like I'm teetering
on the edge of the abyss of my ignorance,
and I shall leave it to
my friend Harry Scheiber
to declare when I have fallen in.
"On February 7, 2008 Anglican
Archbishop Rowan Williams
set off an international firestorm,
by suggesting that some
accommodation of Muslim family law
was quote, "Unavoidable in England."
His suggestion though carefully qualified,
prompted more than 250
articles in the world press,
the vast majority denouncing it,
and denouncing the Archbishop.
England as critics charge will be resets
with licensed polygamy
and barbaric procedures
and brutal violence against women
encased in suffocating burkas.
Muslim citizens of a Western democracy
will be subject to legally ghettoized
Muslim Court's immune from civil appeal
and constitutional challenge.
"Consider Nigeria and Pakistan
"and other former English colonies
"that have sought to balance Muslim Sharia
"with the common law,"
other critics added.
"The horrific excesses and
chronic human rights violations
"of these religious courts, even ordering
"the faithful to stone
innocent rape victims
"for dishonouring their families,
"prove that religious laws and state laws
"and marriage in the family
simply cannot coexist,
"case closed," said the
Archbishop's critics.
This case won't stay
closed for long however.
The Archbishop was not necessarily
calling for the establishment
of independent Muslim courts in England,
let alone the enforcement
of Sharia by English courts.
He was instead raising
a whole series of hard
but unavoidable questions
about marital cultural
and religious identity and practice
in Western democratic societies
committed to human rights
and religious freedom for all.
What forms of marriage should
citizens be able to choose?
And what forums of religious marriage laws
should states be required to respect?
How should Muslims and
other religious minorities
with distinct family norms be accommodated
in a society dedicated
to religious liberty
and self-determination,
to religious equality
and non-discrimination?
Our legal pluralism, and perhaps even
a form of personal federalism necessary
to protect Muslims and
other religious believers,
who are conscientiously
opposed to the liberal values
that now inform state laws
on sex, marriage and family.
These and other hard questions
are becoming unavoidable
in many modern Western democracies
with growing and diverse
Muslim communities,
each making new and ever louder
demands for accommodation.
If current growth rates
of Muslim communities
in the West continue,
a generation or two from now
the so-called Danish cartoon crisis
is gonna seem like child's play.
Even democratic countries that
share a common law heritage
and a common commitment to human rights
and religious freedom for all,
have taken quite different approaches
to these basic questions.
Take three examples, England,
Canada, and the United States.
Of these, England has the largest group
of religious Muslim minorities
and has been the most
accommodating of Muslim schools
and charities, and banks
and arbitration tribunals
that litigate and adjudicate
the private issues of
their voluntary faithful.
In particular, English courts
are increasingly upholding
the arbitration Awards of Muslim tribunals
in marriage and family disputes,
so long as all parties
consent to participate
and so long as there is not a hint
of any physical coercion
of any of the parties.
The same deference is accorded
to the miracle arbitrations
of Jews, and Hindus and Christians
and other peaceable religious authorities.
Canada, the most constitutionally liberal
of these three common-law countries,
debated seriously in the last decade.
The recognition of Sharia
marital tribunals in Ontario,
and a bit in Quebec as well.
But ultimately, after
ample cultural contestation
rejected them in favor
of single provincial laws and marriage
for all citizens Muslim,
and non-muslim alike.
But Canadian and Muslims
enjoy ample religious freedom
to engage in their own
worship and apparel,
education, banking,
religious rituals and more
and have no other serious impediments
upon their religious group rights.
The United States, though a sizeable
and diverse Muslim populations
has been the least accommodating
of its Muslim citizens.
American Muslim that against
have not fared well of late
when they have challenged
state denials of charters
or exemptions for their
schools, charities or mosques.
Nor have they often succeeded
in challenging prohibitions
to wear traditional religious apparel,
from head scarves to burkas
while teaching in public schools,
or testifying in state courts
or serving in public places.
Most Americans State courts
have only sporadically
upheld private Muslim marriage contracts,
and that trend is in a downward direction.
They have often sided with
non-muslims spouses in divorce
and child custody cases
involving mixed marriages.
They have always held a firm
line against Muslim polygamy
and have granted shrinking deference
to arbitration awards
and mediation settlements
when Muslim officials have been involved.
But, American Muslims
have continued to agitate
for greater religious freedom,
autonomy and
self-determination in marriage
and related domestic subjects.
It is no surprise that
it is the law of marriage
and family life, that has
triggered this new contest
between law and religion
and Western democracies.
For marriage has long been regarded
as both a legal and a
spiritual institution,
subject at once to special state laws
of contract and property,
and to special religious
canons and ceremonies.
Marriage has also been long regarded
as the most primal institution
of Western society and culture.
Aristotle and the Roman Stoics called
the marital household, the
foundation of the polis
and the private font of public virtue.
The Church Fathers and
medieval scholastics
called it the seedbed of the city,
the force that welds society together.
Early modern protestants
called the household,
a little church, a little
state, a little seminary.
The first school of love and justice,
charity and citizenship.
John Locke and the
Enlightenment Philosophers
called marriage the first
society to be formed
as men and women moved
from the state of nature
to an organized society,
dedicated to rule of law and
protection of natural rights.
Because of its cultural importance,
marriage was also one of
the first institutions
to be reformed during the decisive battles
between church and state
in the history of the West.
In the fourth and fifth centuries
when Constantine and
his imperial successors
slowly converted the Roman
Empire to Christianity,
they soon passed comprehensive
new marriage and family laws
predicated directly on Christian teachings
that gradually soaked into the Roman law.
In the later 11th and 12th centuries
when Pope Gregory VII, and his successors
threw off their civil rulers,
and established a Catholic Church
as an independent legal
authority in Western Christendom,
the church seized jurisdiction,
lawmaking power over marriage
calling it a sacrament
subject to the church courts
and to the law of those
courts, the Canon Law.
In the 16th century, when Martin Luther,
Henry VIII, and other Protestants
called for reforms of
church state and society,
one of their first acts was to reject
the Catholic Canon Law of marriage
and the sacramental
theology that supported it,
and to transfer principal
legal authority over marriage
to the Christian magistrate.
In the later 18th century,
when the French revolutionaries
unleashed their fury against
traditional institutions
they took early aim
at the Catholic Church's
complex marital rules
and rules and rituals consigning marriage
to the rule of secular
state authorities alone.
And in the early 20th century,
when the Bolsheviks completed
their revolution in Russia,
one of Lenin's first acts was to abolish
the legal institution of marriage
as the bourgeois impediment
to the realization of true communism.
Modern Western democracies
have not abolished
marriage as a legal category,
but they have dramatically privatized it
and thinned out many of
its traditional elements.
Half a century ago or
so, most western states
treated marriage as a public institution
in which Church, State and society
were all deeply invested.
With ample variation across jurisdictions
most Western states in
the middle 20th century
still generally defined marriage
as a presumptively
permanent monogamous union,
between a fit man and a fit woman,
with capacity and freedom
to marry each other.
A typical state law required
that engagements be formal
and that marriages be contracted
with parental consent and witnesses
after a suitable waiting period.
It required marriage
licenses and registration
and solemnization before officials.
It prohibited sex and
marriage between couples
related by various blood and family ties,
identified in the Mosaic law.
Couples who sought to divorce
had to publicize their
intentions to petition a court
to show adequate cause or faults
to make provision for
dependent spouses and children.
Criminal laws, outlawed
fornication, adultery,
sodomy, contraception, abortion
and other perceived sexual offenses.
Tort laws held third parties liable
for seduction, enticement,
lost a consortium,
alienation of affections of one spouse.
Today by contrast, a
private contractual view
of sex, marriage and family life
has come to dominate the West.
With little constructive role left to play
for parents or peers or
religious or political officials.
Marriage is now generally treated
as a private bilateral
contract to be formed,
maintained and dissolved
as the couple sees fit.
Private prenuptial, marital
and separation contracts
that allow parties to define
their own rights and duties,
within the marital estate and thereafter
a gained increasing acceptance.
No-fault divorce statutes have reduced
the divorce proceeding
to an expensive formality
and largely obliterated the procedural
and substantive distinctions
between annulment and divorce.
Payments of alimony, non-going
forms a post marital support
to dependent spouses and children
are giving way to privately negotiated
lump sum property exchanges,
providing a clean break
for parties to start anew.
The functional distinctions
between the rights of the
married and the unmarried couple,
the straight and the gay partnership
had been considerably narrowed
by an array of new statutes
in constitutional cases.
Virtually all, traditional sex crimes
save incest and polygamy have
been constitutionally outlawed
or become dead letters.
These exponential legal changes
in the past half-century
have in part been efforts
to bring equity and equality
within marriage and society,
and to stamp out the
patriarchy paternalism
and claim prudishness of the past.
These legal changes are also
in part simple reflections
of the exponential
changes that have occurred
in the cultural and condition
of Western families.
The stunning advances
in reproductive and medical technology,
the exposure to vastly
different perceptions
of sexuality and kinship
born of globalization and immigration.
The explosion of international
and domestic norms of human rights,
particularly gender rights
and children's rights.
The implosion of the traditional,
nuclear family born of new economic
and professional opportunities for adults.
But more fundamentally,
these legal changes
represent the rise of a new
theory of private ordering
of the domestic sphere,
and the gradual growth
of a new democratization of desire.
A fantastic range of
literature has emerged
in the past four decades,
vigorously describing, defending
or decrying these legal changes.
Many Muslims living in the West,
decry these massive changes
to prevailing state laws
of sex, marriage and family
life and they want out.
Some Muslims have just gone back
to their Muslim majority homelands,
shaking their heads in dismay
at what Western libertinism is wrought.
Others have stayed put and quietly ignored
the State's marriage and family law
using the shelter of constitutional laws
of privacy and sexual autonomy,
to become in effect a law into themselves.
Others have developed
elaborate, premarital contracts
that seek to exempt Muslim
couples for much of the state law
in favor of internal norms and practices
of their own religious communities.
And still others have
led by cultural lives,
dividing their time between Western homes
and Muslim majority lands that allow them
to form a Muslim marriage in a family,
including such an institution
that licenses polygamy,
patriarchy and primogenitor.
All of these informal methods
of cultural and legal coexistence however,
can only be temporary expedience.
These creaky accommodations
and concessions that now exist
in various Western lands for
Muslim citizens and subjects
can easily fall apart.
Eventually, a Muslim citizen
will appeal to the State
for relief from a
religious marriage contract
or a religious family practice
that he or she cannot
abide, but cannot escape.
Eventually an Imam or
a shadow Sharia Court
operating in the West will overstep,
by using force or issuing
a fatwa that draws
the ire of the media and the
scrutiny of a state official.
Eventually an aggressive
State caseworker or prosecutor
will move upon a Muslim household,
bringing charges of coerced
or polygamous marriage.
Eventually a Muslim school or charity
will find itself in court,
faced with a suit for
gender discrimination
or with child abuse, owing to its practice
of single sex education
and corporal punishment in the school.
Eventually another major media event
like that surrounding
Rowan Williams stray,
unavoidable accommodation comment of 2008
will bring a bright spotlight back
on Western Muslim communities.
And once such a major
case in controversy breaks
and the international media gets involved,
many of these informal
and temporary domestic arrangements
for Muslims, might well unravel,
particularly given the cultural
backlash against Muslims
prompted by 9/11, 77 Fort
Hood and the unpopular wars
against Islamist extremism
in Iraq, Afghanistan and elsewhere.
It's precisely this vulnerability
that advocates of faith-based family law
and Sharia Courts want to avert.
They want to put Sharia,
the family law of the Muslim community
and it's voluntary use
by the Muslim faithful
on firmer constitutional and
cultural ground in the West.
But rather than denouncing
Western liberalism,
and the sexual moral and marital lassitude
it has purportedly occasioned.
Sophisticated advocates now
press their case for Sharia
in and on the very terms of
Western constitutionalism
and political liberalism.
Three main arguments are part
of the literature today
at the cutting edge.
The first part of the case for Sharia
is an argument for religious freedom.
Both Western constitutional laws
and international human rights norms
give robust protection
to the religious freedom
of individuals and groups.
Why, the argument goes,
should peaceable Muslim citizens
not be given freedom to
opt out of state laws
on sex, marriage and family,
that run afoul of their
core claims of conscience
and central commandments of their faith?
Why should they not have
the freedom to choose
to exercise their domestic lives
in accordance with the norms
of their own voluntary
religious communities?
Why doesn't freedom of religion
provide a sincere Muslim with protection,
against a unilateral divorce action
or a child custody order by a state court
that directly contradicts
the rules of Sharia?
Why doesn't freedom of religious exercise
empower a pious Muslim man,
to take four wives into
his loving permanent care
in imitation of the Prophet,
particularly when his secular
counterpart can consort
and cavort freely with four women at once
and then walk out scot free?
The second part of the case for Sharia
is an argument for religious equality
and non-discrimination.
After all many Western Christians
do have religious tribunals to
govern their internal affairs
including some of the family
matters of their faithful,
and state courts will generally
respect their judgments
even if these cases are appealed
to Rome or Canterbury or Moscow.
No one is talking of
abolishing these church courts
or even trimming their power,
even after recent discoveries
of grave financial abuses
and cover-ups of clerical
sexual abuse of children
in selected churches.
No one seems to think that
these Christian tribunals
are illegitimate when some of them
discriminate against women, in decisions
say about ordination or church leadership.
Similarly Jews, are given
wide authority to operate
their own Jewish law courts,
to arbitrate marital and
financial and other disputes
among the Orthodox Jewish faithful.
Indeed in New York State by
statute and several other states
and European nations by custom,
courts will not issue a civil
divorce to a Jewish couple
unless and until the Beth Din,
the Jewish law court
issues a religious divorce.
Even though Jewish law
systematically discriminates
against the wife's right to divorce.
If Christians can have their Canon laws
and consistory courts,
if Jews can have their
Halacha and beth din,
and if even indigenous peoples,
can have their ancestral
laws and tribal rulers
why can't Muslims be treated equally
in their use of Sharia and Islamic Courts?
The third part of the case for Sharia
is an argument from political liberalism.
One of the most basic teachings
of classical liberalism in the West,
is that marriage is a pre political,
a pre legal institution.
Marriage is not created by the State,
it comes before the state
and it's positive laws
both in historical development
and in ontological priority.
As John Locke put it famously
in his two treatises on government,
the marital contract
was the first contract
and the first society to
be formed as men and women
came forth from the state of nature.
The broader social contract came later
presupposing stable marital contracts.
And contracts deformed state governments
and religious communities and
other voluntary associations
within this broader contract
as society came later still.
Why on this simple contractarian logic
should the State get
exclusive jurisdiction
lawmaking power over marriage?
After all, it was 16th century Protestants
not 18th century
enlightenment philosophers
who first vested the state
with marital jurisdiction.
But why is state jurisdiction
over marriage mandatory or even necessary?
Before the 16th century
Protestant Reformation,
and in a number of Catholic lands,
well after the Reformation
to the Catholic canon law
and Catholic Church
Courts, govern marriage.
Moreover, even in Protestant
England until the 19th century
the state delegated to
ecclesiastical courts
the power to treat discrete
marriage and family issues.
There is evidently nothing inherent
in the structure of Western
marriage and family law
that it requires it to be
administered by the State,
And there's nothing ineluctable
in liberalism's contractarian logic
that requires marital
couples to choose the State
rather than their own families
or their own religious communities
to govern their domestic lives,
particularly when the
state's liberal rules diverge
so widely from their own
religious beliefs and practices.
On this latter argument,
conservative Muslims sometimes join hands
with selected conservative Christians
and selected critical liberals
who call for exemption from,
if not the abolition of
state marriage law.
Conservative Christians,
because the state has purportedly betrayed
traditional Christian
teachings on marriage.
Critical liberals, because
the state has purportedly
continued to encroach too much
on individual privacy and sexual autonomy.
So, those are the three big arguments
religious freedom, religious equality
and this contractarian argument.
Let's sort them out and try to give
some preliminary answers.
The problem with the
first pro Sharia argument
from religious freedom,
is that it falsely assumes
that claims of conscience and
freedom of religious exercise
must always trump, but
that's hardly the case
in modern democracies,
even though religious
freedom is amply cherished.
Even the most sincere and
zealous conscientious objectors
must pay their taxes,
register their properties,
answer their subpoenas,
obey their court orders,
swear the roads or give
other forms of veracity
and abide by many other general laws
for the common good
that they may not in good
conscience wish to abide.
Their eventual choice if they persist
in their claims of consciousness
is to leave the country,
or to go to prison for contempt.
Moreover, even the most
devout religious believer
has no religious exemption claim
from criminal laws for
activities like polygamy
or child marriage, or
female genital mutilation
or corporal discipline of wives
or coerced marriage of young daughters,
even if their particular brand
of Sharia might command it
or their particular religious
community might commend it.
The guarantee of religious freedom
is not a license to engage in crime.
Muslims who are conscientiously opposed
to the liberalism of Western laws
of sex, marriage and family
are certainly free to ignore them.
They can live chaste private
lives in accordance with Sharia
and not register their religious
marriages with the state,
that choice will generally be protected
by the constitutional rights
of privacy and sexual autonomy
so long as that conduct
is truly consensual.
But that choice also leaves
their family entirely
without the protections,
rights and privileges
available through the state's
complex laws and regulations
not only of marriage and family,
but also marital property and inheritance,
social welfare, life insurance,
Social Security benefits
and much, much more.
And if minor children are involved,
the state will intervene to ensure
their protection support and education
and will hear nothing of
religious freedom objections
from their parents
or from the communities religious leaders.
Western Muslims enjoy
the same religious
freedom as everyone else,
but some of the special accommodations
pressed by some Muslim
Sharia advocates today,
in the name of religious freedom
are simply beyond the pale
for most Western democracies.
Even further beyond the pale,
is the notion of granting
a religious group
legal sovereignty over the
sex, marriage and family lives
of their voluntary members.
It's one thing to allow
religious officials
to officiate at weddings
or testify in divorce cases
or assist in the adoption of a child,
or facilitate the rescue of
a distressed family member.
Most Western democracies
readily grant Muslims
and any other peaceable
religious communities
such ready accommodations.
Some democracies only a few
will also uphold the
religious arbitration awards
and mediation settlements,
over discrete domestic issues
that are engineered by Muslim
and other religious authorities,
but that's a long way
from asking the state
to delegate to a religious
group the full legal power
to govern the domestic
affairs of their members,
in accordance with their
own religious laws.
No democratic state,
can readily accommodate
a competing sovereign to govern
such a vital area of
life for its citizens.
Especially since family
law is so interwoven
with so many other public,
private, penal and procedural laws
and especially since so many other rights
and duties of citizens turn
on a person's marital or familial status.
Putting aside the formidable
First Amendment obstacles
to such a delegation of core state power,
to a private religious body,
surely a democratic citizens
status rights and entitlements
cannot turn on the judgments
of a religious authority
that has none of the due process
and other procedural constraints
of a government tribunal.
Moreover, the proud
claims of Muslim advocates
that Sharia provides a
time-tested and comprehensive law
governing all aspects of
sex, marriage and family life
is for some an even stronger strike
against its accommodation by the state.
"Once a state takes the first step
"down that slippery
slope," skeptics argue,
"There will eventually be little to stop
"the gradual accretion
of a rival religious law
"over sex, marriage and family life.
"Particularly as Muslim
communities grow larger
"and more politically powerful."
Some Western states thus resist
even religious arbitration
and mediation of marital disputes
involving Muslim officials.
We saw last year Oklahoma passed
a constitutional amendment
saying, "Sharia does
not apply in our state."
Nine additional states
are now contemplating
such anti Sharia measures.
Six European nations have
those under advisement
at the national level,
that trend will continue.
The pro Sharia argument from
liberal contractarian logic,
the argument that says,
"Since marital contracts
are pre political,
"coming before the contracts
that form the state,
"the society or religious associations
"marital parties should be free to choose
"whose laws govern them."
That argument is clever,
but deliberately incomplete.
It ignores another elementary teaching
of classical liberalism,
namely that only the state
and no other social or private union
can hold the coercive power of the sword.
The government contract does grant
this coercive power over individuals,
but only in exchange for strict guarantees
of due process of law equal
protection under the law
and respect for the fundamental rights
of citizens and subjects.
A comprehensive system of
marriage and family law,
let alone the many other
correlative legal systems
of inheritance and trusts
and family property.
Children's rights, education,
Social Welfare and much more,
cannot long operate without coercive power
given the transience and the porousness
of our modern communities.
Such a law needs police,
prosecutors and prisons,
subpoenas, fines and contempt orders.
Material, physical and
even corporal sanctions.
Moral suasion and example
communal approbation
and censure could certainly
do part of the work.
But a properly functioning marriage
and family law system in a modern society
requires resort to all these
coercive instruments of government.
And only the states and
not a religious body
can properly use these
coercive instruments
in a modern democracy,
again with strict due process constraints.
The pro Sharia argument
from religious equality
and non-discrimination.
Because Jews and Christians
have their religious tribunals,
we should have them too.
Takes a good bit more effort to parry.
A useful starting point is the quip
of Supreme Court justice
Oliver Wendell Holmes jr.
"The life of the law has not
been logic but experience."
This old adage has bearing on this issue.
The current accommodations made
to the religious legal
systems of Christians and Jews
First Peoples and others in the West,
were not born overnight,
they came only after centuries
of sometimes hard and cruel experience
with gradual adjustments
and accommodations
made on both sides.
The accommodation of and by Jewish law
to Western secular law,
is particularly
instructive in this regard.
It is discomforting, but
essential to remember
that Jews were the perennial
pariahs of the West
for nearly two millennia.
Consigned at best to second-class status
and periodically subject
to waves of brutality
whether imposed by Germanic purges,
medieval pogroms, early modern massacres
or the 20th century Holocaust.
Jews have been in perennial diaspora
after the destruction of Jerusalem
in the year 70 of the Common Era.
Living in a wide variety of legal cultures
in the West, and well beyond.
One important legal technique of survival
that Jewish communities developed
after the third century of the Common Era,
was the concept of Dina d'Malkhuta dina,
the law of the community, is our law.
This meant that Jews accepted
the secular law of the legitimate
and peaceful secular
ruler who hosted them,
as the law of their own Jewish community,
so long as it did not conflict
with core Jewish laws.
This technique allowed
Jewish communities over time
to sort out which of
their own religious laws
were indispensable,
which more discretionary.
Which secular laws and
practices could be accommodated
which had to be resisted even
at the risk of life and limb.
This technique not only
led to ample innovation
and diversity of Jewish law
over time and across culture,
it also gave Jews the ability to survive
and even to grow legally even in the face
of ample and bitter persecution.
Western democracies in turn,
particularly in the
aftermath of the Holocaust
and impartial recompense for the horrors
it visited on the Jews,
have gradually come to accommodate
core Jewish laws and practices.
But it's only in the past two generations
and only after endless
litigation and lobbying
in state courts and legislatures,
that Western Jews have finally gained
legal ground to stand on.
And even that ground is still thin,
and crumbles at the edges at times.
Today Western Jews generally have freedom
to receive Sabbath day accommodations,
to gain access to kosher food
to Don yarmulkes and distinctive grooming
and other forms of religious dress
in most public places
to gain zoning land use
and building charters, for
their schools and charities
and synagogues to offer single sex
and bilingual education
in those schools and more.
And Jewish law courts have
gained the right to decide
some of the domestic and financial
affairs of their faithful
who voluntarily elect to arbitrate
their disputes before
them, rather than suing
a fellow Jewish brother and
sister in a secular Court.
These Jewish law courts are
attractive to Jewish disputants
because they are staffed
by highly trained jurists
conversant with both
Jewish and secular law
and sensitive to the bi-cultural issues
that are being negotiated.
Unlike their medieval and
early modern predecessors
these modern Jewish law
courts claim no authority
over all Jewish sex,
marriage and family life
leaving many issues to the state.
And these Jewish law
courts have also abandoned
their traditional authority,
to impose physical coercion or
sanctions on the disputants.
In particular they claim no
authority beyond persuasion
to stop a disputant from
simply walking out of the court
and out of the Jewish
community, altogether.
The modern lessons in this story
for Sharia advocates are four.
First, it takes time and patience
for a secular legal system to adjust
to the realities and needs
of new religious groups
and to make the necessary
legal accommodations.
The hard one accommodations
that modern Jewish law
and culture now enjoy,
are not fungible commodities
that Muslims or any others can claim
with a simple argument from equality.
These are individualized
equitable cultural adjustments
to general laws that each
community needs to earn for itself
based on its own needs
and its own experiences.
Muslims simply do not have the
same history of persecution
that the Jews have faced in the West,
and simply do not yet have
a long enough track record
of litigation and lobbying.
Concessions and accommodations will come
but only with time, with
persistence, with patience.
Second, it takes
flexibility and innovation
on the part of the religious community,
to win accommodations from
secular laws and cultures.
Not every religious belief
can be claimed as central,
not every religious practice
can be worth dying for.
Over time and of necessity,
diaspora Jewish communities
learn to distinguish
between what was core
and what more penumbral,
what was essential and
what more discretionary
to Jewish legal and cultural identity.
Over time and only grudgingly,
Western democracies learned to accommodate
the core religious beliefs and practices
of Jewish communities and citizens.
Diaspora Muslim communities in the West
need to do the same.
Islamic laws and cultures
have changed dramatically
over time and across cultures,
and modern-day Islam now
features immense variety
in its legal religious and
cultural practices and norms.
That diversity provides ample opportunity
and incentive for Muslim
diaspora communities
to make the necessary
adjustments to Western life
and to sort out what is core
and what is more discretionary
in their religious lives.
Cultural adaptation, not assimilation
is what is needed to win the
accommodations of the state.
Third, religious communities in turn
have to accommodate or at least tolerate,
the core values of their
secular host nations
if they expect to win concessions
for their religious courts
or religious practices.
No Western nation will long accommodate,
perhaps not even tolerate
a religious community
that cannot accept its
core values of liberty,
equality and fraternity
or of human rights
democracy and rule of law.
Those who wish to enjoy the freedom
and benefits of Western society,
have to accept its core constitutional
and cultural values as well.
So far only a small and brave band
of mostly Western trade Muslim
intellectuals and jurists
have called for the full
embrace of democracy
and human rights in and on Muslim terms.
These are highly promising arguments
and courageously proffered.
But so far these arguments
can hardly be heard
amidst all the loud denunciations of them
from sundry traditional
Muslims in and beyond the West.
Moreover even liberal
Muslims, are hard-pressed
to point to modern examples
of a Sharia based legal system
that's maintains core democratic
and human rights values.
Unless and until that case
can be reliably made out,
deep suspicions will remain the norm.
And finally Muslim tribunals in the West
must become a good deal
more legally sophisticated,
and procedurally equitable
to be both attractive
to voluntary Muslim disputants,
and acceptable to secular state courts.
Like the Jewish Beth din that
sits in New York or in London
the Muslim law court needs
to be staffed by jurists
who are well-trained
both in religious law and in secular law,
and who maintain basic
standards of due process
and representation akin
to those in secular courts
or secular arbitration tribunals.
A single Imam pronouncing legal judgments
in an informal proceeding
at the local mosque,
will get no more deference
from a state court
than a single priest or rabbi
making legal pronouncements
in a church or in a synagogue.
And Western state courts
will have little patience
with claims that this lack of deference,
violates the religious liberty
of the mosque or the Imam
or the members before the Imam.
The courts suspicions will
in fact be the opposite
that the disputing parties
who appeared before the Imam
did not understand the full legal options
available to them at state law
or were coerced to participate
in the internal religious procedures
abdicating their states rights.
It's much harder for a secular
court to have such suspicions
when educated Muslim
parties eyes wide open
choose a legally sophisticated
Muslim arbitration tribunal
over a secular court that does
not share their core values
but still offers them a
serious jurisprudential option
to state marriage law.
Lest all of this seem like an
unduly patronizing argument
for religious minorities, to wait and see
or change and hope for the best.
It's worth remembering,
that majority Christians too
went through much of this same exercise
in the area of religion and education.
The American story offers
a good illustration
of how this developed and how
common educational standards
were eventually raised and maintained.
In the later 19th and early 20th century,
a number of American
states wanted a monopoly
on education in their public,
that is their state-run schools.
Some of this agitation was
driven by anti-catholicism
some by anti religious animus altogether.
For half a century churches,
schools and religious parents
struggled earnestly to
protect their rights
to educate their children
in their own private religious schools.
And in the landmark case
of Pierce versus Society
of Sisters in 1925,
the United States Supreme
Court held for the churches,
and the families and
ordered American States
to maintain parallel public
and private education
options for their citizens.
But in a long series of cases thereafter,
courts also made clear that states
could set basic educational requirements
for all schools as a
matter of accreditation,
setting mandatory courses
and texts and tests
mandatory standards where
teachers and students,
common requirements for laboratories,
libraries, gymnasia and more.
Religious schools could add
to the state's minimal
accreditation requirements,
but they could not subtract from them.
Religious schools that sought
religious freedom exemptions
from these requirements
found little sympathy from the courts
which instructed the schools
either to meet the standards
or to lose their accreditation
and licences to teach.
This compromise, on religion and education
forged painfully over more than
half a century of wrangling
has some bearing on issues
of religion and marriage.
Marriage like education
is not a state monopoly,
even if state marriage
law must be a prerogative.
Religious parties in the West
have long had the right to
marry in a religious sanctuary
following their religious communities
preferred wedding liturgy.
Religious officials have long
had the right to participate
in the weddings, annulments
divorces and custody battles
of their voluntary members.
But the state has also long set,
the threshold requirements
of what marriage is
and who may participate.
Religious officials may
add to these thresholds
state law requirements on marriage,
but not subtract from them.
A minister may insist
on premarital counseling
before a wedding even if the state
will allow the couple to
be married without it,
but if a minister bullies a minor to marry
out of religious duty, the
state could throw him in jail.
A rabbi may encourage a bickering couple
to repent and reconcile,
but he cannot prevent them
from filing for divorce,
except in New York.
An Imam may preach of
the beauties of polygamy,
but if he knowingly presides
over a polygamous Union
he is an accessory to crime.
If religious Tribunal's do eventually
get more involved in
marriage and family law,
states may well build on these precedents
and set threshold requirements
in the form of a license
a kind of accreditation.
Formulating these license rules
through a democratic process
in which all parties of every faith
and non faith participate.
Among the most important such license
or accreditation rules to consider,
no child or polygamous marriages
or indeed any other forms of marital Union
not recognized by the state.
No compelled marriages
or coerced conversions
before weddings that
violate elementary freedoms
of contract and conscience.
No threats or violations of life or limb
or provocations of the same.
No blatant discrimination
against women or children.
No violations of basic rules
of procedural fairness and more.
Religious Tribunal's may
add to these requirements
but not subtract from them.
Those who fail to conform
will lose their licenses
to arbitrate disputes and
will find very little sympathy
when they raise religious
liberty objections.
This type of arrangement
worked rather well over time,
to resolve some of the
nation's hardest questions
on religion and education.
And it led many religious schools
slowly to transform themselves
from backwards sectarian isolationists,
into exemplary cultural leaders.
Muslims in the West
have already begun some
of this exercise too
in the development of Muslim
grade schools and high schools
which are now sometimes
attractive to non-muslims
because of their discipline
and high academic standards.
And one can imagine in
the next decade or two
arising alongside a Notre Dame or a BYU
a Oriya Shiva new school
that has Muslim religious identity.
Such an arrangement
holds comparable promise
for questions of religion and marriage
in western Muslim communities.
It not only prevents the descent
into licensed polygamy
and barbaric procedures
and brutalized violence
that Archbishop Rowan Williams's
critics properly feared,
it also encourages and incentivizes
various Sharia tribunals
to reform themselves,
and to pick those marital laws
from that vast canvas of
Sharia, that are most conducive
to abiding by Western cultural standards
and constitutional norms.
Even hardened and
prejudiced local communities
and Democratic lands,
eventually will find room
for new Muslim minorities
who are skilled at cultural navigation
and who are both consistent and persistent
in pressing their main
case for accommodation.
The Catholic example in
America is a good example.
And in the process of
adjusting to the legal
and cultural realities of their new homes,
Western Muslim religious minorities
may eventually become
legal and cultural leaders
of the law of marriage
in succeeding generations of the West.
Thank you very much for
your kind attention.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)